so you know when you were a teenager
your parents maybe your mom or dad sat
you down and had to drop conversation
with you do you remember that what if I
told you as bad as drug dealers are to
you and I or to kids there's a dealer
that's ten times worse than drug dealers
and we'll get to that in a minute but
let me go back to the drug dealer
business model and let's talk about how
this works said you know a couple weeks
ago I'm going home and I see this guy on
the side the homeless guy and he's
sitting there with the Sun and I seemed
there all the time I said I'm not gonna
give you money but are you hungry said
yes as I watch you get into cars against
it gets in a car I take him to the
Wendy's and we eat at the Wendy's I said
what do you want he says this is what I
like I said you want to get some stuff
for your friends he says yes I get him
some other stuff he gets in the car and
I said listen so how did you get here
he says heroin said how would you I said
twenty said twenty-eight I said what was
the decision what was a turning point he
tells me I was just dating a girl and
she started using and we use it to have
sex so I used it as well and the next
thing you know I got up I said man when
are you gonna change it says this year
so one is this year anyways we had a
great conversation together here's a
kicker I dropped him off here's what he
says thanks Patrick I said what he says
thanks Patrick this guy knows the
content and his heroin addict and he's
going after to Wendy's with me and he
says thanks Patrick okay there's nothing
where my name was mentioned or see
anything for him to be able to say
thanks Patrick gets that I'm like wow
here's a guy that has access to some
information but heroin completely
changes life now let's go back and look
at the business model of drug leaders
here's how it works if you ask the
average person who they use drugs with
the first sample will they tell you
probably a friend right all my friend or
a girlfriend or something like that all
this other stuff now there are some that
will tell you a drug dealer offered me
some weed for free or drugged did it
give me a little bit of cocaine or a
little bit of crack or a little bit of
acid or a little bit of LSD or a little
bit of something here's a half a pill of
ecstasy tried and then you get what look
now the business model of a drug dealer
what kind of a customer does a drug
dealer want the one that buys one time
or B backs they won't be backs and what
kind of be back sit in one they want to
be back that has friends that brings
other people that also buy with them for
example I'm going to a nightclub man I
got to go get some coke I got to go
get some X I gotta go get some you know
I gotta go get some Special K whatever
it is
hey you guys got to try this boom I come
and I get it right I'm gonna be back
customer he keeps making money off of me
and I keep coming back now say friends
that find out I'm an addict and I'm
using too much and you start noticing
certain changes I remember when I was
off for drugs and I was a kid coming up
there's always the one friend that wants
to help the other friend do you remember
that friend there's always the one
friend that always comes down and says
dude you got to stop man I mean I
remember you did I'm not seeing this
going to the right you just leave me
alone you sound like my dad you sound
like my mom I don't want to hear it dude
I'm not your dad or mom bro I'm just
telling you this isn't good dude you're
good basketball player you're good in
class you're good baseball what are you
doing bro eventually a person has a
moment and they leave now here's the
other side there's also stories of how
eventually that drug addict pushes the
individual to a breaking point where it
cost them their lives how do most drug
dealers stories end up think about that
question how do most drug dealers
stories end up what happens to most drug
dealers that hurt a lot of people they
either end up in jail or somebody
eventually eventually retaliates why
because there's only so much you can do
when you take someone's life listen I've
had my friends where one committed to
suicide drugs and emotional I've had my
friends that use a lot of drugs that got
off of it and I'm at friends who never
used anything all of them right you know
what typically happens with that drug
dealer jail somebody retaliate stay like
that for too long so here's the point
what is the lifespan of an addict let me
say one more time what is the lifespan
of somebody who likes using cocaine what
is the lifespan of somebody who uses
ecstasy what is the lifespan it's
typically in your youth right
they say married people have better
lives and they make more money why
because the distractions are gone if you
settle down and you get married and you
have kids what typically happens to you
you start thinking about what what I
want my kids to use drugs so what do you
stop doing you stop using drugs
hypothetically let's just say that's the
scenario right remember how earlier I
told you there's something worse than a
drug dealer
let me tell what's worse than a drug
dealer
here's what's worse than a drug dealer
fear dealers now what is a fear dealer
let me explain - it's a fear dealer fear
dealer is somebody who sells you fear
non-stop all day all night and you know
what's the business model of a fear
dealer they sprinkle it with a little
bit of entertainment they get you in
they give you a little bit of fear you
go spread it to your friends they get
the fear where did you get the fear from
from such-and-such a network they get
attracted to that network they buy more
fear more people business come back and
watch it next thing you know I'm
recruiting for my fear dealer right now
here's the difference typically when
you're somebody's on drugs you can tell
it on their eyes you can tell by the way
they're constantly itching hair on you
can typically tell while they're going
like this all the time or or you know
one of these things you know what it is
when somebody's typically on drugs right
you know the mannerisms if you've seen
it or somebody who's on xanax or you
know those shows they they can't even
talk to you I've been around all of it
so I know alright hey you know didn't
paranoia yet I've been around all of it
you can tell there is no side effect of
fear that's public or visual that you
can see because it's all here you can't
see it here like when you're afraid
people don't go like this like they
don't they don't roll their words when
they're coming out you can't tell and
what happens to most people most people
entire lives they become addicted to
fear what gets taken away from them
dreams capacity potential sanity their
freedom they're arrested for the rest of
their lives and then one day they wake
up one day they wake up and they say man
what the hell happened to my life I'm 76
years old but you know at that time at
that point what they're typically doing
at that point I've already typically
sold their kids corner selling their
grandkids who are selling their great
grandkids and they're sitting there
saying holy freaking moly fear dealers
converted me and I bought their drugs
for 50 years and guess what I did I sold
that drug to my kids and my grandkids my
entire family is now afraid how the hell
did this happen to me
this is why it's so subtle you don't
have any network or statistic or
Huffington Post article or BuzzFeed
article or Washington Post article to
read about the consequence of fear
because you cannot see it right but the
damages are so ugly it pretty much takes
your life away now we may go bury
somebody six foot under because they
became a cocaine addict and I've been to
many many funerals when I just went too
many of them have relatives right now
that can give up certain drugs and you
call them at night their roommate says
they've been missing all night from 12
o'clock to 6 o'clock
why are you missing 12 o'clock to 6
o'clock and you're not somebody in your
20s and 30s you're somebody in your 50s
what are you doing being missing at that
time okay and then they come back and
their sleep and throughout the day and
hey I need my money my car broke down my
this broke them people are not night
people know what's going on and you go
to their funeral painful right but
there's no nothing real difference
between physically dying and your dreams
dying you're just existing you ain't
doing anything crazy with your life
because somebody got to hold your fear
and it took all your dreams away so if
you're watching this you may say Pat you
sound like you're high right now no
problem you sound like you're crazy
right now what are you talking about
this makes no sense to me don't worry
about it go to a different network
that'll sell you exactly what you're
addicted to all I'm telling you is start
questioning everything think for
yourself every single time somebody
sells you fear push back this is not a
message you can only hear one time this
is a message I can do 100 episodes in a
row with this topic over and over and
over again with a different story
it still is not gonna get enough people
to convert but eventually enough of you
are gonna say this makes a lot of sense
and if you have experienced losing
somebody to drugs if you have
experienced losing somebody to fear if
you have seen people completely lose
their dreams because they got sucked
into fear afraid of starting a business
afraid of chasing their dreams afraid
that they can do afraid of all afraid
that all these other people are better
than it because they have degrees if you
want to put a stop to it share this
video with people let's see if we can
get 10,000 shares let's see if we can
get people watching the scene you know
why I'm so
Encarta to fear dealers then go on
twitter and post and say i am no longer
gonna allow fear dealers to sell me
their garbage I'm done you can't sell it
to me anymore and spread that language
to other people as much as possible
until people start saying you know what
man I am addicted to fear and I need to
put a stop to this and once you do you
it's like it's like life opens up it
goes from black and white to color you
start seeing things you never saw before
but you got to put a stop to it you got
to stop using the drug that these
dealers are selling to you it's called
fear it's just as dangerous as all the
other ones except this one takes your
dreams away and your potential away and
once you do that expect some exciting
things to happen to your life very soon
you